what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch today from our buddy
warren over the cosmic wonder thor love
and thunder teaser trailer update major
news yes saw going around that there was
stuff going about toys revealed go to
our expert warren to break it all down
for us hit that like button if you're
here let's jump into it and see what
he's got to say
so today's news is actually coming
straight from marvel it's coming from
marvel's website marvel.com in which
they have wow new lego sets to us that
offer a lot of information about the
movie now lego leagues are typically
pretty common for marvel movies so it
just kind of looks like marvel is
getting a jump on the gun here and
posting it themselves before leaks
actually come out which is really smart
on their part and of course yeah
nowadays a better look at the movie and
there are actually some pretty decent
reveals here now these aren't actually
all lego some of them are titan hero
series and some of them are fx series
but all offer a much better look at the
movie including some character costumes
and some new characters but let's start
with thor's costume because he has a
brand new outfit and it is really blue
as you can see it is really really
different
i love it
i love it well sweatpants and a hoodie
but before that in his fight with thanos
he was pretty much wearing all black and
a little bit of silver now his suit
looks to be completely blue with gold on
it and this is really cool because it
looks like phase 4 seems to be the phase
of comic accurate costumes because this
blue and gold suit really resembles the
first thor costume ever designed by jack
kirby it's an iconic look and it looks
like we're finally getting that on the
big screen well it's interesting too
because you know we just had eternals
this year their gods and their own right
their norse mythology god looking at his
costume there actually it feels kind of
reflective of what they did with some of
the costumes in the internals cast as
well so it's pretty neat to see that
kind of correlation and color scheme and
pattern actually connect because mcu
connects everything and then we get a
look at jane foster's thor who is
labeled mighty thor on a lot of these
toy sets that we'll talk about today now
this is who she is in the comics in the
mighty thor storyline when she picks up
mjolnir she becomes the goddess of
thunder the mighty thor so again
sticking to comic accurate things here
and i really really love it now her
outfit isn't 100 comic accurate like
when they first introduced the mighty
thor but it looks actually pretty damn
true
a little bit more modern which obviously
of course in the mcu you could expect
that and we actually get a much better
look at both of these costume designs on
some other toys that are released we
have mjolnir mighty fx mjolnir and a
stormbreaker on stormbreaker we get a
better look at thor's costume on the
right there with official promo art that
they're using we can see this okay it is
blue and gold it's got a ton of gold on
it and for jane foster's we can get a
better look at her suit here as well it
looks to be silver and like a reddish
brownish color but we get a pretty good
look at her helmet here which is going
to be awesome to see her wear and we
also see that mjolnir is repaired but it
is still cracked yeah i mean that's kind
of what i was first noticing too is that
thor keeps stormbreaker and maybe
in the movie i don't know what happens
in the movie we've got truth
but but maybe in the movie somehow
milner is called to her or she calls to
milner in some way like if we're going
off of the comics if she has a character
who's like you know suffering with
cancer and somehow she's drawn to milner
maybe that's like where some of the
powers
source comes from i could absolutely see
that again like one with chris hemsworth
with the stormbreaker and then one with
jane foster with malener pretty neat to
have you got both doors yeah plus things
can have weapons jealousy yes
i mean that'd probably be a great comedy
but it's like what you're worthy of this
is my hammer mjolnir will be rebuilt but
it looks like it might have some flaws
in it now speaking of comic accuracy the
mighty thor is a story where jane foster
does become thor but she has cancer and
ultimately every time that she picks up
the hammer and transforms into the
mighty thor her cancer gets worse and we
know because taika wichita has revealed
this to us that this is going to be
somewhat of the same storyline we're
going to get in thor love and thunder
jane foster is going to have cancer so
i'm sure much like in the comics in the
mcu becoming thor might not be the best
thing for her so we'll have to see where
this story goes i think she'll live i
think they'll find a way to put her in
remission by the end of the video yeah
so i keep selling them damn toys
you just got natalie portman back at
work come on now here's something that i
am super excited about and i think a lot
of people are really going to love this
we have our first ghost lego set
and marvel
a goat boat which is a viking boat oh
that is actually pulled by two goats
i'm super excited to finally see why mcu
thor's two goats tooth and naturally
yeah
grinder in the comics thor can summon
both of these goats at will he can also
dismiss them at will and they pull his
mystical chariot of course thor can fly
with his hammer what tooth nasher and
tooth grinder can travel anywhere within
all of the realms they also help thor
transport things because yes he can fly
with his hammer but he can't exactly
carry a lot but these aren't just your
average goats they're the goats of goats
they actually have good limes
they kind of eat everything including
people they both possess super strength
and they can actually damage mjolnir
that's how strong they are and like i
mentioned they can travel through all of
the realms at very high speeds and they
can do this on land or simply through
space so yes they can fly and if we look
at this picture of this lego set it does
look like they are pulling this viking
ship through space it actually looks
like they are traveling through
different dimensions if you can see all
the lights behind the ship here it
definitely looks like it's space travel
or it could actually be dimension travel
and since the multiverse is being
introduced it's like traveling yeah
comes out and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness multiversal by
frost nito i love it you know about them
i mean a little bit from just you know
vague amounts of research over the
intervening months but yeah before and
this probably explained the extent of
what i can tell you i mean i got two
thoughts here one i wonder if they'll
talk in the movie and then taika waititi
will get some comedic actors to fill in
the role two if they kill off one of
them damn ghosts i'm gonna be pissed off
at this movie they do it for some cheap
dramatic effect to break the audience's
heart no no don't do it cliche to kill
off the classic terror keep them alive
and get their own spin off goat holiday
special disney plus and on the back of
the boat here we can actually see thor
fighting gore in this set the characters
that are included as said on the box are
the mighty thor which is jane foster
four which is you know our normal thor
king valkyrie is what it says here and
of course
asgard now not queen but king korg of
course so that with a slight tone in
your voice
you should try and imply man butcher now
what's really interesting about this is
that if you look closely enough we can
see on the front of the ship it says a
gear asgard tours now there's two parts
that make it really really interesting
one is the first place
now this is probably the name of the
boat and it makes sense because in
marvel comics a gear was the god of the
seas pretty much like neptune except
this is the norse god ager so it would
make sense that they named their ship
after the god of the sea but it also
says asgard tours now remember asgard is
now on earth and people are aware of
asgardians because thor is actually
quite famous we found this out during
thor ragnarok in the beginning where
people came up to him and asked to take
his picture and they also knew that thor
and jane broke up so thor is kind of
celebrity so it would make sense that
people would actually go to asgard to
kind of be tourists there and it looks
like asgard has kind of embraced it a
little bit after all they're probably
going to need a little bit of money at
least so that would probably be a pretty
decent way of making money giving tours
i feel like i just put together a little
plot theory in my head not like a major
plot theory just kind of a setup if
people are visiting there i imagine jim
will get diagnosed with cancer and then
she'll want to go visit thor maybe sarah
goodbyes or something like that while
thor is off with the guardians left off
at the end of end game she goes to visit
new asgard and that's when thor returns
back
that's about it i don't really have like
some mind-blowing revelation there yet
it's more like what's the setup too
jane's already connected with king
valkyrie and you know started to unravel
her situation and then thor gets back
and then valkyrie will advocate for jane
there you go
yeah nothing special we'll see see what
the trailer does this also means that
the trailer shouldn't be that far away
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness comes out a month before thor
love and thunder and they gave us a
moment
everything feels so much further away
than it actually and that is kind of
where we're at right now with thor love
and thunder we're about five months away
because it comes out july 8th of 2022 so
we're actually less than five months
away from the release of thor love and
thunder now if you combine that fact
with the fact that marvel is now
officially releasing things like this
toys legos official art for the movie
this means that promotion for love and
thunder is about to ramp up this is an
extremely good sign that they're getting
ready to release that trailer promotions
are beginning to start and we have less
than five months until the movie comes
out so i would expect the first teaser
trailer relatively soon if marvel sticks
to the same thing they've been doing we
hopefully get it within a month but as
always the day the batman comes out that
first teaser trailer i'll of course do a
video on it letting everybody know
better well that was some good [ __ ] man
feel like i learned quite a bit there
goats goats
so excited to see some damn goats in my
life guys subscribe to ward if you
haven't done so already we're gonna do
our best to be on top of whatever this
thor 11 thunder trailer comes out that
means a lot of waking up needlessly at
six in the morning to go not out and
then going back to bed and then finding
out it dropped a moment after i went to
sleep
that's the life of the real region
simple but complicated
guys leave your thoughts down below
we'll talk with you soon
[Music]